hey
Oh
Oh
well thank you so much for doing this
with me thank you for inviting us yeah
are you ladies having a good day yes
it's project for awesome day oh okay
what does that mean you know about that
I don't know it's a charity date it's a
charity day on YouTube run by the vlog
brothers where everybody puts up
fundraising videos and comments and
likes to raise money for various
charities and of course we support
because I am a girl which is about the
charity in our show oh my gosh how cool
so it's a big day today yeah check it
out and I'm going to after this that's
on sunny well yeah I was just I'd been
going through I watched almost every
episode of your show in one sitting and
I loved it mainly because I watched like
I read every Nancy Drew book as a kid so
when like how did you guys kind of come
up with the idea and how is it why did
you decide to use transmedia and then
Madison how did you kind of get involved
you just kind of want to give a general
overview and then we can do specifics
and so like you on big Nancy Drew II i
will as a big Nancy Drew reader i'm also
a big fan of Veronica Mars and a bit of
television writer for a very long time
I've worked in kids and I've also worked
in drama and I had a lot of experience
writing mystery in it seemed to me a
real shame that there were no mysteries
on television right now for kids and so
I took my I concept for a girl detective
to the web why did you decide that the
web was something that you really wanted
to join especially for kids because I
feel like it's so there's not a lot of
kids shows online at all which is a huge
and crazy mistake because kids are the
most rapid users of online video of
anybody and and they they don't care
they have no no preconceived notions
about whether something's been on
television or whether it's original to
the web they just weren't looking for a
good story um and I've always I
personally have always been involved in
in
kind of interactive media I had a
software company in the 80s and made
software for the Atari 400 and the
Commodore 64 so so those are those are
kind of some of the very first computers
that home computers that they're ever
work and I'm hoping that the internet is
caught up and is ready for for us to be
really making entertainment eat well
Madison how did you kind of get involved
how did you decide you know what I want
to do this web series and has it been a
big change from being in film well um
it's not very different for me at all
like filming web and filming TVs is
pretty much the same thing for the
process of it but I got involved i
audition for it so it was more that they
they chose me to do it and there was
just a really exciting thing to be
involved with I think it's a great
character it's a great it's a great
story and it's really fun to do so
there's no real like choice it was just
I definitely want to do this for sure
the second so mad I the second I saw
Madison's even her picture I Nikki was
the Ruby scribe that I wanted and then
she came in and gave the world's
greatest audition it was perfect there
was no question in my mind that she
would be Ruby and it is a tremendous
pleasure to watch her perform in the
school oh that's so sweet how was the
audition process like uh it was a
exactly the same as any television
audition it was sunny my agent sent me
and they gave us one or two scenes to
see two scenes um and remember i
memorize the lines and then came in did
it the way that I practiced and then
Kelly the director gave some notes and
you did it again and then that was it
and then a couple days later and my dad
called me at work is like you are you
got the part I'm also lots been said
that's awesome what is your favorite
part about this character for both of
you
oh you evil voice well what I love about
Ruby is that she have she is unstoppable
when she gets something in her head she
just goes after it without any thought
to the consequences and I love her
determination in that respect and I love
story wise what that leads to yeah I
like that that she's very she's very
much like a real person she's very
relatable she makes a lot of mistakes
and she's like a big she's a big person
and will own up to it after and she's
just she's a very even though she makes
a lot of mistakes and doesn't
necessarily do well and everything that
she does she still somebody that you can
look up to and who you know is a good
person one thing pretty clear I've
always wanted to ask this when you're
developing characters like this do you
find that little bits of your own
personality or like pieces of people
that you know come into like they're
writing or the acting of this character
absolutely they in it I right Ruby Skye
PI with my writing partner Julia
strassman poem so I think in many
respects Ruby's voice is a kind of a
combination of the two of our the best
parts of both of us and a and then I
mean certainly when we when we went to
when we wrote the first script it really
was that and now it's in the second
season it's also partly Madison too
because we've watched the first season
over and over again it's get the field
when we when we write for him in hmm in
what ways can fans really interact with
Ruby because there are so many features
online but what are like the most
popular ones what have you kind of had
to change along the way well I mean what
we what we have in this season is you
can solve the clues along with Ruby so
in every episode we put the clues the
chief lines up on our website and we
found a lot of people who are solving
those along with us and then we have a
lot of kind of world building websites
in our world so the Haunted library this
season is is called the oh deary
librarian at oh deary library com you
can go and
to that site and sort of see some stuff
about the characters but also book
reviews and and so on what we're finding
is that the people who are watching this
season particularly a really avid book
readers they are really intrigued by you
know the books that are mentioned in the
show and the clues that are built around
them so we've sort of gone on to youtube
and found all the booktubers the people
who review books and my bro suck they
are book reviews into our oh deary
website so that's a way to interact with
the property a little bit in track but
you know to put your favorite give us
your favorite book reveals to share with
our community how doesn't really i
didn't even know that was like a big
community that's really neat it's a huge
community and another thing that's been
really great for us is we have for
tumblr blogs supporting the show Rep
someone is just sort of like the Ruby
Skye PRI will tumblr and then we Ruby
little sister Haley has a tumblr Diana
not in the mean girl has a tough mnship
girls who are the fictional band have a
tumblr and we've had a lot of sharing of
the gifts we put up there so we've built
a lot of gifts around the show and those
those on the community really seems to
like to and even just that it's on
YouTube I mean it gives people a chance
to comment as incus gives us a chance to
see people's feedback right away whereas
if it was just on TV or something you
wouldn't get that feedback and get those
views of the likes or anything so that's
even I think a pretty big part of the
interaction with the audience we're all
when i whenever we get a subscriber is
going to their you do yeah i like seeing
who they are and see who's watching it
yeah and watch their videos i love that
did you think that it would grow to this
proportion i mean i feel like it's you
have a huge fan base like you're getting
into season two like did you dream that
it would be this big like a good you
know i have a good fantasy yeah
look ah but a dad but you know we I'd
like to I'd like Ruby to exist for a
long time I'd like her to have the kind
of life that Nancy Drew has had and take
her into other platforms and so on see
if we can you know I think a girl
detective I think it's a fascinating
character for many of us and I just I
just like to see everything live on in
many ways how do you hope that she
continues growing boss oh okay you be
building something like that as well as
continuing our web series mean I feel
like books is something that no one ever
brings up when I talk to them i love
that that was the other way around yes
it is always the other way around so
it's very cool well what do we all have
in store for the next season coming up
with relief um well I think we've got a
couple of ideas that we're playing
around with that one of them would be
called the maltese puppy and Ruby's
little sister Haley has a dog-walking
business because Haley does everything
and when she gets sick she sends Ruby
out to walk your dogs and Ruby comes
back with an extra puppy and that would
be the mystery of the maltese puppy to
find out where that is up to you obvious
and so that so that's one of the stories
were working on right now and since our
director Kelly harms has just gotten a
new dog I feel very confident about
shooting with the dog with dolls well
Madison what do you kind of have on your
plate now besides that i'm not i'm in
school i'm in university so that's
pretty much my biggest thing oh I have a
job hostess / waitress so that's another
thing but I've up around Toronto for
other things but I'm not working on
anything at the moment so hopefully
something will come up soon if you were
to give advice to someone else
you came and they didn't really
understand transmedia just and they
wanted to develop a series what advice
would you have for them balancing all of
these different I mean you have four
tumblers you have a youtube channel it's
so much content like being able to have
people come to your site and feel like
they know what they're doing they're not
overwhelmed with content how do you
manage that well that there are a few
few questions there but i'll choose the
you know what what what advice do i have
for people i would say you know we're in
an unprecedented really wonderful time
right now for people who want to make
things and you want to build things for
to reach an audience and my first piece
of advice would be go out there and make
something do it within your budget
within your time constraints with your
resources but make something because
there's an incredible pleasure making
things and also the ability we have
right now to connect with our audiences
which we haven't had in the media for a
really long time and and then you know
be open listen to the audience and see
what they want to do take their
suggestions because that's how you how
you build things that people like this
by listening to them and if they say
except the key box yeah and if they say
you know I like the funny books do the
funny voice if they say skip the scary
bit skip the scary bits and the same as
telling a story to a little kid you know
one on one we have this really cool
thing now where the audience can respond
to you in a way that they never put into
the impalement a great time to take
advantage outside yeah thank you so much
again for doing this thank you now we'll
have a good rest your day okay you too
happy holidays I'll happy holidays good
meeting you both all right
you